[Music]
this great big story is made possible by
Lexus experience amazing mazes are one
of the most fascinating things almost
everybody who as soon as they can crawl
always wanting to find out what's hidden
what's out of sight my name's Adrian
Fisher I live in Dorset in England and I
create mazes and labyrinths all over the
world well I spent the first few years
of my career in accountancy there came a
moment when I'd created amazing my
father's garden and then I started
building one and two more and so on and
then I suddenly realized this was gonna
be far more fulfilling if I spent my
life creating mazes this is the site of
the place this is 40 meters in diameter
and the Moses going here over the years
of created mazes in some 40 countries
and I guess I've built over 700
full-sized mazes in the landscape
I think a maze design is a very easy
tarek art you sketch out ideas and
develop ideas on paper and drawings but
one of the exciting things is amazes a
network now amazes a special kind of
network where I decide there's only one
start point I decide where the finish is
and I make sure that every single bit of
it can be as confusing or as easy as I
wish I'm trying to make it as ingenious
and tricky as possible but in the end
I'm also an entertainer I'd like to
leave clues that help you solve it and
you feel so good about yourselves when
you have beaten the maze designer like a
good movie you get to the end the new
stool you don't want it to stop I'm
appealing to some basic instinct to miss
all that want to be entertained an
explorer and amazes an ideal way of
doing that its purpose is totally to one
side of normal sensible practical things
in life but give so much pleasure to so
many millions
[Music]
all the machines in this arcade homemade
there's something magical about all this
as a child I found that making things
that made people laugh was satisfying
and seemed more point in doing that than
making useful machines
[Music]
I'm Tim Duncan and I'm a cartoonist and
engineer I have two arcades
one on the coasts and appear and this
one in central London called novelty
automation in total I suppose I've made
about 50 machines not many people have
that as their ambition in life but yeah
it's six feet this is pet or meat you
spin the wheel and you find if the land
ends up sitting with you on the sofa or
being carved for dinner it was a hobby
that got out of control
this is Auto frisk you stand in front
here the gloves inflate and then they
act you down Britain's got a great
history of satire and I suppose I'm not
really particularly political myself but
I think it's healthy for little people
to poke fun at the rich and powerful you
fly this little drone around this
Beverly Hills mansion and see all the
stars inside and your paparazzi you have
to try and take the photos to fill up
the cover of the magazine I get my ideas
from lots of places it's partly things
happening in my life partly things
happening in the news and partly from
old arcade machines and mechanisms this
is test your nerve you have to put your
hand inside the cage with the mad dog
for as long as you dare
to do something like this you have to
enjoy the process of making things I
spent most of my life solving
conventional engineering problems rather
than thinking up the jokes this is the
chiropodist you have to take off your
shoe for this one you put your foot in
the treatment bay down the bottom and it
feels really weird seeing people
enjoying using the machines keeps me at
it
and also because they take money it
provides the income to let me keep at it
so to me it's a pretty perfect system it
sure beats working I never planned my
career or anything about my life it's
just occasionally a sort of opportunity
comes up and then I go through to be or
not to be that is the question whether
tis nobler in the mind to suffer the
sins and I was a very just fortunate
consequence to see if troubles and by
opposing end up to die to sleep to sleep
perchance to dream other micromachine
man hey presenting a genuine original
colossal collectible most minutes of the
real thing Micro Machines a lot of
people know me as the micro machine man
or the FedEx guy or a terrible test a
virgin from Saved by the Bell or just
that guy who talks fast in fact I was in
the Guinness Book as the world's fastest
talker and so for the last 40 years if
you needed a fast talker I was your
go-to guy is that okay did you get
everything you need I mean I can repeat
it again if you want you sure you don't
want to do
when I was 12 years old I wanted to get
into the Guinness Book of World Records
so I figured the only thing I could
really do since I wasn't gonna eat a car
or swallow lead-pipe was to lock myself
in a room and teach myself fast-talking
and I did that with the hamlet soliloquy
to be or not to be here's later I'm at
this party fancy California Beverly
Hills party and a friend of mine is
trying to pick up this valley girl he's
from New York and talking pretty quickly
and she looks at him and says Nick oh my
gosh are you like the world's fastest
talker and he says no as a matter of
fact this person is they called me over
and I did one of my little party
routines because I come up to pick a cup
up to feed might be difficult to pick up
a club and a guy walked over he says
that's incredible I'm a producer and I'm
gonna put you on a show I went on the
show and I did the fast-talking thinking
that would be it and all of a sudden the
phone starts ringing and I'm booked all
over the place and I managed to make a
living out of it I can speak as fast as
11 words a second now I never do 11
words a second for TV well let me do
Peter Piper at 11 words a second pick up
to pick up up to be back to pick typical
speed up I picked can you kind of hear
me going pop pop pop but that's really
all you're kind of getting but when you
do TV there's visual reinforcement
people see you and do whatever so I do
about seven to eight words a second that
would sound something like now on radio
I have to do it even a little slower
because you have no visual reinforcement
you're not seeing me so that I do about
five to six words a second so it sounds
something like and that's kind of the
secret to my success because if you
can't understand what I'm saying they're
not gonna pay me the big bucks now the
very first commercial I did was the
Federal Express commercial
it is to this day the most award-winning
commercial in the history of advertising
the final scene I'm sitting behind the
desk and I'm going you know Dave what's
the deal with the deal are we dealing
David's deal with Don if it's a deal
with Doc so I did the thing like 29
times without making a mistake
and the director said to me what are you
like a machine you never make a mistake
I said you want a mistake I'll give you
a mistake the next time so I said
David's a dork with dick Don and duck
and that's the take he ended up putting
in the commercial the first time I saw
it I call this John it's our little
secret although I'm known as the world's
fastest talker I do not choose to live
by entire life in the fast lane
sometimes I just like to take it all a
little slower but sometimes it's really
really good to be fast
[Music]
[Music]
this is Justin Schmidt yeah my name is
Justin Schmidt
he's an entomologist and I'm an
entomologist I basically studied
stinging insects he's been stung by a
lot of insects I've probably been stung
at least a thousand times he reviews
insect stings the way a somali a reviews
wine pure intense brilliant pain like
walking or flaming charcoal with a
three-inch nail embedded in your heel
which insect was that that's the bullet
and this is his lab in Tucson
this is his harvester and this is his
vinegaroon this is a tarantula hawk
these are some more harvester ants in a
park near his lab he is the creator of
the Schmidt pain scale the Schmidt pain
scale is basically a scale to rate the
painfulness of stinging insects on a
scale of one to four a one would be a
sweat B two would be something like a
yellow jacket was the three would be
something like a harvester ant and a
four would be a tarantula hawk how bad
is a four four it's absolutely
excruciating the debilitating
incapacitating just shuts you down just
absolute sheer pain there's just nothing
you can really do about that I don't
think I'd want to be stung by a whole
bunch of different for I don't think I
could endure that for very long let's be
clear justice Schmidt doesn't just go
out and get stung on purpose it's just
that he's dedicated his life to studying
well my passion is insects and stinging
insects in particular yeah I get stung
but that's that's all just part of the
passion you know what that gives me data
you know sting helps me in understanding
what the insects doing and I get to be
out in the sunshine and out in the rain
out in the environment
these magnificent beautiful insects just
just such a joy I can't imagine anything
I'd rather do more
[Music]